there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey it's us again in its
episode 114 only one more episode until
the Halloween episode yeah that's gonna
be a pretty good episode we got Shauna
coming over again yeah Shauna and Eric
are coming over
we'll make Garrett talk to ya we and we
have like a [ __ ] ton of stories that
really cool stories that people sent in
we have all kind of fun so if we're
gonna do actually somebody had a good
suggestion one of our listeners said hey
why don't you guys play your card game
that you invented like on the show my
crimson drop on a crystal palette card
game and I was like hmm
I don't know we'll see how it goes yeah
I mean they're coming over tomorrow and
we're gonna like try and record you know
pieces of it all day and then kind of
edit together the best stuff so we'll
see how it goes if we if we get into
that we might get oh then I think it'd
probably take a long time and would it
be a lot of editing how long would it
take to play a game um it depends on how
quickly people can figure out the murder
yeah so you know just depends on how
good your investigation skills are not
quite an answer about how long does it
take to play a game you think about an
hour what did I just say it depended
Vance okay it's like you know it's like
clue is it how good is your detective
for dinner raising I never deductive
reasoning is really good then it won't
take discuss sound crazy I think I've
only played a board game maybe two or
three times what kind of childhood did
you have I didn't play that did you like
grow up on the moon I think I played
Monopoly once and I never I didn't even
get through the game I'm you so I don't
really like I like board games there is
this one we call Parcheesi
yeah I played when I was a kid yeah yeah
I you know checkers in shapes like
mystery mansion there's like all that
kind of [ __ ]
I've never played anything like what
made there or clues I don't know
anything about it I don't mean I don't
know if it's a three hour game or
four-hour game or a half hour I've never
played a game of Clue that was three
hours that's for sure
there's only so many solutions to the
mystery you know what I mean so it's not
gonna like it's to turn me out into a
show we'd have to learn how to edit we'd
have to we'd have to edit it the right
way well yeah but I have like the funny
that well yeah that's why we're that's
why I'm doing it ahead of time but like
I said we'll see how it goes it's just
you know you know how we do we never
like [ __ ] plan anything yeah so we
just kind of go with the flow of
whatever is happening yeah but it seems
to be serving as well so far I kind of
thinking though to do that we probably
need a cameraman yeah perhaps all right
yeah so I don't know but yeah we'll see
how it goes because we're gonna start
recording the Halloween show tomorrow so
other than that like I said it's we're
recording this on Friday night we've got
our drinks you've got all our stuff you
know yet serial killers tonight right it
is we're going back to true crime these
both of these have been requested by
various listeners so I decided to do a
whole European true crime type of thing
first part of the show we're gonna be
talking about the infamous monster of
Florence and then the second half of the
show we're going to be talking about the
vampire of Hanover otherwise known as
German serial killer first Harmon I also
have a news story this time around
because one of our listeners sent us a
sent us a news story about a new trial
of like a British killer okay and
they're retrying him so I'm just gonna
like talk about that the news though
before we get to the news though got to
mention the audiobook has been slowed
down a little bit because you had such a
huge workload graphic design yes it's
totally recorded Jenny just has to get
through there and edit it and then send
it up to him really we're hoping maybe
another week yeah I mean I was hoping I
was shooting for getting it done this
week but then as sometimes happens I
ended up getting several very large
graphic design jobs from several
different clients pretty much on the
same day good and walk away Matt yes so
yeah so I got really backed up with
with the audio recording and stuff like
that bunch of packages and stuff she's
got a make yeah so most of that is out
of the way now so I'm kind of hoping
that you know as next week comes along I
can get back to editing like I said it's
all recorded I just have to like go
through and take out all my fuck-ups
yeah me when I make too much noise yeah
I was like well you know waiting on that
I know that you know we're trying to get
it get out to you as soon as possible
yeah that's it goes on the market what's
his cat no no I don't have time for Yuki
I don't have time for that she really
wants she wants to get branches brush
sure yeah she wants to get brush um what
else is going on well let's see um
check out our last movie review which
was the Evil Dead yeah
also check out this is gonna go up on
Tuesday right so our second episode of
our 13 o'clock matinee show will be out
on which we watched what the hell do we
watch first man we watched bad times at
the El Royale and we watched Christopher
Robin so check that out if you haven't
already media week yeah well you know I
really liked actually I liked all the
movies this week but you know yeah
you're always growing about something
he's like a Christian Robin was okay
he's coming it's becoming taxing to
watch all these movies for these people
oh man poor baby go to the theater no
problem taking time out of my motorcycle
ride oh you it's so hot though I don't
it's not really you don't like to ride
motorcycle is somewhere anyways it's
Florida man you can't really go outside
in the trailer in Florida it's you just
do you like a turtle in your shell just
waiting for it to boil yeah you're just
like when when is it not going to be
4,000 degrees outside so starry night
life really good show last weekend well
actually it'll be the weekend before
last
yeah after the show we went to the hotel
with him well we were supposed to be
going to an after-party yeah yeah we
know where's the hotel that was me you
to other goth girls woman's name was
Shannon yeah another ones day yeah she
was the girl who did the art cover art
for the for the I forgot her name I knew
it but I forgot and then Michael was
there so funny because they had to have
get separate rooms
well only yeah cuz Howard snores so much
only Howard gets his own room that's
something it's all rooms we didn't know
we thought we're gonna drop off Howard
is like worried ego yeah yeah Michael
Michael was playing all these [ __ ]
games with me man it was second funny
cuz when you look at Michael you know I
mean he's kind of like this kind of has
like an effeminate appearance to it you
know it kind of like a kind like a real
skinny Robert Smith and the way he
accidentally but the dudes all man so he
tries to do is he tries to like get into
these piss and matches with me in front
of girls all right they're hilarious
he's coming up to me trying to out
testosterone me okay with these girls
these captains are sometimes there's a
man sometimes a man tries to come up
next to me and be more of a man than me
but the testosterone thing doesn't
really kind of work out but the
difference when he stands next to me the
only kind of man he could ever be it'd
be like a whoa man I look back then I go
whoa man what are you packin it's uh I
want to make him feel listen I don't
want to make him feel too effeminate all
right so he comes up talkin smack to me
he's got a telephone receiver just the
receiver just to receive like an
old-fashioned one
yeah like light blue it's bright blue
and it's on a cord that goes into his
cell phone I'm assuming yeah yeah but I
thought it was that way he could pretend
like he's talking on the phone while
he's talking on the phone
I never seen he [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
did any talks on the phone like a 16
year old girl and he starts [ __ ] with
me with this damn phone and I
take the phone from it I take the
receiver from him and I start talking to
somebody we were pretty loaded and I'm
talking we drank a lot yeah we drank a
lot I can't really explain it but there
was nobody on the other end
obviously instead of instead of [ __ ]
with him directly I started [ __ ] with
him indirectly as though you were
talking as if I was talking to somebody
else about him yeah it was very funny I
wish I could remember exactly what he
said because he was trying to outdo me
it's right you can't out kamikaze me I'm
a true kamikaze something back there is
no shame yeah I brought some a whole
tube of it [ __ ] like yeah oh now she's
fart he flirting with me the girls were
laughing you know games they were so
good you know how when you know how when
you see two dogs one two male dogs and
what I'm trying to get on top of the
other and it goes no no no no Nikki they
keep doing this of whoever is in the
dominant position that's what he was
trying to do with me that was a very fun
like I said well the problem was that we
they asked us to get there early so we
could hang out for like an hour before
they went on yeah stage so we got we
entered this place at like 7 o'clock and
then we didn't get home until 4:30 yeah
and that girl came with us yeah she got
kicked out of the room she want to sleep
in the bathtub he's like you sleep in
here it's like we had to take her home
so we just she had a sleep in our guys
in our guest room yeah and she was like
I have to be at Yoga 10:00 in the
morning morning so you [ __ ] at Yoga
I'm not taking you there she woke us up
yeah woke me up spider fingers on me
girl was in our room she lives in st.
Peter's like it's like 60 miles seven
miles I had to get up out of bed early
and drive this and she needed a ride no
she do yoga she was gonna do yoga in the
cemetery and at a place called baby land
where all the dead babies were I was
like yeah we're like driving around I'm
like wow this is really big that's it
and then we drop and I'm like baby lands
down they're gonna do dude yoga in her
goth outfit with a big old fat platform
boots and [ __ ] baby yeah you gotta pop a
finger photograph of her she's trip
looking [ __ ] I know we only just met her
at the show we wanted to do that the
Halloween show with us but she can yeah
she was actually gonna come over
tomorrow yeah Halloween gibberish you
can't come with like I said the she
lives kind of far away but yeah so let's
see what else is our story
yeah um as usual if you would like to
financially support Shane go to our
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast we have had one new
patron this week whose name is John hey
there thank you very much and also one
of our previous patrons Sondra has
increased her support I've doubled it
so that's in this past week so all right
words you know we're just plugging along
on the patreon and if you want to help
us out like I said you know the patreon
page or you can get our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast WordPress that there's a
like a design bar to a PayPal account
where you can give a one-time donation
if you would like to do so yeah and
check out a story night yeah you should
really good man I just plugged him told
story about mine they are hilarious and
they're really really good Michael
writes all their lyrics - yeah yeah yeah
and they're like I said they're really
nice I didn't know I didn't know he
wrote him yeah I realized he was that
talented I'm gonna slap that [ __ ] right
in those lyrics now sitting I got
respect for him now I got to go respect
him now next time I need something I
know Michael thank you [ __ ] I plan
those [ __ ] punk gangs to me it from
those girls oh come on it was hilarious
yeah that's hilarious it's trying to
earn points off me you know talk about
yeah he's jealous you think
that's what I'm gonna say that's how
almost Peter loves me man all right well
all right so enough with these
shenanigans yeah let's get today you
guys know what's going on I got tequila
that's why it goes this way I still need
to do I still need to do the keloid
shirt I just have I have made a badass
tequila shirt that's gonna have an Aztec
sundial with two aztec silhouettes of
Aztec hottie chicks on either side kind
of like kind of like our RL shirt kind
of like our real shirt but it's gonna be
like a Mexican version of the real shirt
and it's gonna have you know a piece of
it's gonna have like a symbol for agave
and then another symbol for for
pineapple and another symbol for guava
and that's the 33 3333 or or one part 1
part 1 part mix of this drink right here
cool cool calm straight out of from
Apocalypto when they're up there on top
of that as pyramids cutting those dudes
hearts out that's what they all right
like I said now I feel really bad cuz we
just like went off on all this like
silly [ __ ] now I was talking about like
bad right I know I just talked about
like partners in song well we'll get
into a disease easy meant to it's trying
to ease into it okay so as I said on the
last show I'm kind of phasing out the
new story thing unless it's sort of
whatever we're doing now actually
somebody did send us send me this a link
to this case good and since I was
already doing European murders I figured
well I'll just throw this on the on the
news story here now this actually
relates back to a double murder that
happened in Britain in England back in
October of 1986 there were two little
girls named Karen Hataway and Nicola
fellows and they were um they were like
walking to their friend's house we're
walking home from school or some like
that and they disappeared and then the
next day their bodies were found in the
woods they
they'd been like raped and murdered
they'd been out there all night
yeah so it was done out there probably
yeah okay so the creepy thing about it
is that they pretty much knew right away
like who it was that did it because
here's this guy named Russell Bishop and
he came out and he said all well before
they found the bodies he said Oh we'll
help you look for them like cuz it was
like you know a bunch of people locals
came out and helped - look the police
look for them so he's like oh I have my
dogs and if they smell the girls clothes
maybe the dogs can find the girls and
all this other stuff but then he started
saying like all this weird kind of
shifty stuff like oh I don't want to
search anymore because if my dogs find
them then I'll get blamed and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so they were like hmm
so eventually they did end up arresting
him and he went on trial however he was
acquitted in 1987 but then three years
later in 1990 he was arrested once again
for kidnapping raping and attempting to
murder a seven-year-old girl damn so he
we couldn't just leave it alone right so
he was put in jail again and the
similarity between that crime and the
original crime from 1986 led police to
believe they're like okay well we need
to re-examine all that because you know
it was 86 87 that they have DNA evidence
but it was very you know very
rudimentary it was very much in its
infancy they said we're gonna go back
and reinvestigate the murders of Karen
had away a nickel of fellows and because
we're pretty sure it was him but there
just was insufficient evidence in 1987
to convict him so evidently they're
doing that now he is still he is on
trial at this moment so hopefully if he
did do it which it kind of seems like he
did because there's other evidence too
it's not just like DNA evidence then
hopefully he will get convicted for it
you know much later than I mean he's
like in his 50s now he was 20 when the
crime occurred but it's kind of scary
though because if he hadn't been you
know if he hadn't been released I mean
the the little girl that he attacked it
1990 who was seven now she she lived she
didn't die I mean but you know it's she
still had that [ __ ] happened to her but
if he hadn't done that then they might
not have even thought to like retry him
mmm
for these two girls so this is like
evidently this is like one of the
longest-running inquiry like in Sussex
history or something like that so like I
said this is it's this is a real new
story it's were like really ongoing the
trial is still ongoing
damn so we'll just see how that [ __ ]
goes so but that's the news story
somebody sent me that so Russell Bishop
like I said guy's name no perv pedophile
yes yeah and probable murderer all right
so now let's get into the case known as
the monster of Florence I've never heard
of this one
now I actually there is a book about
this and interestingly Thomas Harris who
wrote Hannibal silenced the Lambs all
those you know Hannibal Lecter books he
actually attended a trial of one of the
suspected murderers in this case and he
was so fascinated by it that this was
the reason that the book Hannibal was
set in Florence because of this
particular case so he got like a really
interested in it there have been a
couple of books about it like I said now
the confusing thing about it is that
even though it's known as the monster of
Florence which would seem to imply that
it's one killer authorities are pretty
sure that it's more than one and that
maybe it's like an organized gang some
of them might be in prison at the moment
some of them might be dead they're not
real sure they kind of know who some of
them are but they don't know how many
perpetrators are involved this might be
a ring of killers yeah that's what
they're suspecting and they're
suspecting it might be a cult type thing
because some of the murders were kind of
ritualistic all right well lay it on us
tell us how it went down so the monster
Florence case generally refers to
a series of eight double murders that
took place in and around Florence Italy
between 1968 and 1985 because they're
pretty old yeah and some of them they
didn't know until later
like we're related similar to killers
like the Zodiac phantom killer stuff
like that generally couples in cars were
targeted all right now interestingly in
Italy at the time maybe still now I'm
not really sure but since a lot of it
like young Italian people lived with
their parents until they were married so
sometimes they would live in their
parental home until they were like in
their mid-20s car sex is a big thing you
know I mean so like you know cuz they
you know they still live at home so they
go out and have sex in cars and parks
and stuff like that so it's it's
probably a much bigger thing than it is
here
so but that's who the killer is
targeting like I said much like the
Zodiac so they think at this point that
there are at least four perpetrators
maybe more
weirdly they're called they're either
called the Snax companions or the picnic
companions what I'm not really sure why
they call them that they generally
struck when it was a new moon so it was
darker outside I'm guessing I don't I
don't know if that was like a
ritualistic component to the crime or if
they just did it because it was darker
outside and it'd be harder to see them
usually used a 22 caliber beretta pistol
almost all of them had that aspect also
usually did mutilations with knives
didn't usually do anything to the men
but the female victims almost always had
some of them also had breasts removed
damn so they raped no guess they would
know either they weren't raped they
weren't read dhoka not that they know
nothing Noah
um but you know so that's some weird
[ __ ] yeah it's pretty weird and like I
said that's one of the reasons why they
think this is kind of like a ritualistic
sort of group of people like not
necessarily a satanic cult but something
like that like some kind of a cult group
or something
so the first murders that are you know
that fall under the monster of Florence
umbrella this is a woman she's 32 years
old her name is Barbara Lucci now she's
a married woman
but she's well known around town for
being promiscuous let's say what's your
hope her no okay um
she just liked sex and noka didn't just
kind of read me well known around town
for promiscuity and my mind just means
hooker to me usually you she doesn't get
paid that's it's a sportin girl yeah
yeah like I said so uh so there's
Barbara Lucci and her one of her lover's
at the time was named Antonio LoBianco
um she was known as queen bee around the
city and had several lovers going at
once so evidently it's August 21st 1968
and Barbara and Antonio as well as
Barbara's little kid you know she had a
little kid they all went to the movies
now on the way home from the movies the
kid falls asleep in the backseat of the
car so Antonia says hey let's pull over
in the cemetery and well you know yeah I
can show you my edgings right so they're
having sex in the car in the cemetery
and then so this guy comes out of the
darkness and the cemetery and starts
shooting them then the killer takes the
kid picks him up and like spirits him
out of the car how old is the kid um I'm
actually not sure he was old enough to
like talk and everything he was like
five or six okay so because left out of
the car the killer takes the kid to like
a farm house and leaves him on the
doorstep and then takes off okay so the
kid like knocks on the door of this it's
like this farmhouse he tried to save the
kid yeah and and he says something to
the effect of he's like my daddy's in
the hospital sick he's like and I have
to get home because my mommy and my
uncle which is what he called all of my
mom's boyfriend's are both dead in the
car right so creepy but yes so he didn't
do anything to the kid and apparently
the kid never
identified him or anything so the farmer
calls the cops obviously so then they go
to the crime scene at the cemetery they
find it was Antonio's car they found
eight 22 caliber shell casings around
the car now the following morning police
go to Barbara's house and they talked to
her husband whose name is Stefano Mele
now as soon as they arrived at the house
Stefano is running out the door like
with a suitcase
like he's in a hurry right so the cops
are like huh that's a little strange
they said hey your wife got murdered
last night and he's like oh he he just
seemed they said that his reaction was
very strange like he didn't really seem
all that put out about it or upset about
it so you know the cops obviously
thought that was very suspicious so they
said okay well you need to come down to
the station and like talk to us about
some [ __ ] so he gets you down Oh his
wife was fooling around on him yes okay
yes everybody knew from everything I've
read it seems like that [ __ ]
pretty much yeah okay so at the police
station
stefano Mele says no well I've been sick
for the last few days and um you know I
was at home he's like I even had a
couple visitors over both of whom were
also lovers of his wife hmm
and then while they were questioning him
he also brought up this other guy named
Francesca Vinci who was also having sex
with his wife what the [ __ ] how old was
these people she's 32
how old was he um probably he's like the
cook he's cooked out so and evidently
allegedly he says to he's like oh my
wife's not only sleeping with Francesca
Francesca Vinci
she's also sleeping with his other two
brothers right she's busy
who's he sleeping with I don't know I
know
she's like I don't
I'm kidding she's kidding yeah it's a
kiddy world
Katie Sandra
so they keep interrogating him the
following day he says oh well she had so
many boyfriends it's like I'm sure like
a whole bunch of them are suspects which
obviously they would be but then no
sooner is he said that and had he said
that then he said oh by the way me and
Salvatori vinci who was Francesca's
brother we're the ones that killed her
what he's like what we were doing was I
was bitching about her sleeping around
Salvatori said you know you shouldn't
let her do you that way it's like you
know everybody knows and it's really
embarrassing and he's like maybe you
should do something about it so it's
like evidently they both go and they go
to the movie theater they see Antonio's
car outside and then later on they
follow them and apparently it was
Salvatori been she's gone and shot him
dead right okay so he confessed that so
then oh what all these Italian names are
confusing me who was it that pulled the
trigger the husband or one of the
boyfriends no it was the husband got
sick of the husband well that's what he
said so he said he said it was Salvatore
E's gun and Salvatore II told him you
know you need to do something about that
because it's humiliating I was a story
he gave and yeah that was the story he
gave so he said I went over there and
shot them and then I came back and told
Salvatori that they think that he's
lying about this yeah well they're not
really sure not sure they're not really
sure okay so the weird thing though was
that I mean had the dad been the one
that killed because the son that was in
the backseat that was his dad it
couldn't couldn't ID him not as far as I
know I think it was his but I mean she
slept around so much that I'm not really
sure but um you know but she but he
didn't say hey it was that guy you know
what I mean run she didn't seem to like
say anything about that but anyway so
they arrest him right so then the cops
start looking for the gun and they don't
find it and now they come back and they
ask us Stefano about it and then
suddenly he changes the story he's like
no
I didn't throw the gun away I gave it
back to Salvatori he has it and then a
couple hours later he just said never
mind I didn't really do it so he
recanted his confession like pretty much
the day after he made it and then he
said it was actually it was Salvatore
E's brother
Francesco like I said he was also I'm
calm all this [ __ ] on this why would you
why would you confess to a crime then
the next thing I thought I was just
lying it was somebody else
who knows who I know I don't buy that I
think he did do it saying he did do it
then he realized oh man I just screwed
myself I shouldn't have said that
well I mean you'll see how this whole
all right thank God so you tell me
there's more to this like I said you
tell you get like two facts and then you
go off on this big long thing that's
what I do I'm like I'm like not even
this is like the first crime that's what
I'd there's like seven more I'm the
surrogate audience you talk about
everybody else's run jumping to
conclusions to people listening it jump
into conclusions yeah so I'm just
letting you know what they're thinking
why you shouldn't jump to conclusions
okay
[Laughter]
so really so over the next three days
he's basically saying no it wasn't me it
was you know it was this other guy was
Francesco uh anyway the police didn't
really buy it they put him on trial and
he actually was found guilty as the lone
gunman okay so he was he was arrested
was convicted and he was put in prison
now he only got 14 years because they
called it partial insanity because I
guess he was saying oh I was so upset
like they were treating it like a mass
mass loss yeah they treat hear me
calling that right right so they're that
set so Stefano Mele is in prison six
years later in 1974 there was another
double murder very similar double murder
this happened on September 14th 1974 and
there's this little area that was just
north of Florence and this person
walking by they saw a car and there was
two dead people in it this was 18 year
old Stephanie uppity Negro League until
Corey and they called the cops so the
cops get there they find that the young
man is in the car and he's like half
naked presumably they
we're having sex in the car like when
the killer came up and started shooting
at them um he had been shot numerous
times they found these kind of
copper-jacketed shell casings they got
him all around the scene so then behind
the car they find the naked body of the
woman Stefania
and she was like posed the killer had
like spread her out like her arms and
legs were really spread out and then
they had taken like a grapevine branch
and shoved it up her vagina that's what
I was thinking I was like oh that's so
creepy that we just did the evening on
before we go any further you said that
these shell casings were copper-jacketed
yes because there's a problem here me
being a small-arms expert shell casings
are brass all right or they're steel now
a steel casing or that's like military
that's a cheap military stuff Soviet
usually they must be talking about
Eastern Bloc pistol cartridge washed in
brass right don't know brassicas it
couldn't be brass or copper copper okay
probably copper washed steel no such
thing as a copper jacket copper a case
soft what I forgot what is they're
talking about there must be dead did
they identify the caliber they talking
about nine-millimeter Mack it's a 22
automatic beretta okay they didn't do
that the bullets were a Winchester type
that were manufactured in Australia
during the 1950's see that's really odd
I think that was what they definitely
error in in the in the record there
because 22 long-rifle is always a brass
casing now the bullets can be washed in
copper the projectiles
mm-hm but they're never jacketed 20 long
rifle you can't jacket one mom a long
story I think there's look I'm just
there are some people in the audience
that are firearm savvy
so I'm just trying to point out that
there's a problem in the record there
that's not an accurate description of
what they found it was probably some
kind of a they must be talking about a
copper washed projectile they found in
22 long-rifle and cases in brass that's
only I can think of okay just point it
out anyway um okay so the body's the
male victim had was killed with five
bullet wounds the female had been killed
had been shot three times but she had
also been stabbed 96 times with what
appeared to be like a scuba diving type
knife a very large knife
and as I said there were vaginal
mutilation she was left with a grape
vine sticking out of there so so there
was that now like I said this was six
years after the initial the initial
murder now at first they had three kind
of strong suspects one of these was a
guy named Bruno McCauley he was 53 years
old the other one was named Giuseppe
Francini he actually confessed to the
crime but he was kind of you know a
little bit crazy or maybe like mentally
challenged so they weren't really sure
how seriously to take that there was
also a guy named Guido giovannini he was
a lawyer and numerous witnesses had come
forward and said hey we've seen him like
creeping around like spying on couples
in their cars and stuff like that so
these three were like the focus of the
initial investigation into this crime
now at this stage like I said six years
had passed since the first murder so
police were not really connecting them
so much that kind of happened later on
so they you know these three suspects
that they had you know that that should
kind of went nowhere and then the case
in general just kind of went nowhere
then it was several years later before
there was another one the next one
happened in June of 1981 now there was a
guy had he was actually a cop and him
his son were out walking and they came
across again two bodies in a car these
were a 21 year old carmella DiNucci oh
and her boyfriend who was 30 his name
was giovanni fuji
the Carters are closed the driver's side
window was smashed open the male victim
was seated behind the wheel it looked
like his throat had been slashed hmm now
they found the female victim she was
actually not in the car she was about 20
yards away from the car like at the
bottom of like a ravine same as with the
previous victims that her legs were like
spread apart her her clothes were all
slashed up and her vagina had been
removed now most of the mutilations as
these cases went on much like in the
case of Jack the Ripper they're usually
they don't say oh it was a surgeon or
anything that necessarily but they said
it's somebody that knows how to handle
these knives because it was done very
efficiently so you know so that was the
same kind of thing and they don't know
they never found any of the pieces or
they're assuming that the killer cab you
guys yeah like as a kind of a truth yeah
now interestingly this double murder
when they did ballistics tests on the
shell casings that were found they
discovered that it was the same they've
been fired from the same gun as the
previous double murder the same 22
beretta same type of bullets so they're
like okay well obviously now this is a
serial killer investigation right so
then they have this suspect whose name
was again with the cat what's she doing
okay seven with these funny boom one cat
outside and then the other was like well
I know I'm jarem a missile for the noise
that she was making yeah I'm gonna come
yeah I'm just gonna try and not pay
attention it's like kind of distracting
tearing furniture up yeah she's out
there making her little rounds around
the furniture she runs around the
outside upside-down dragging her back
across the ground you think she's a
monkey
it is very think she's a monkey okay so
like I said same gun same bullet same
everything so they think this is the
same killer now the main suspect that
they have at this stage is a guy named
Enzo Spalletti now he is also a voyeur
he had been his car
been seen somewhere around the scene of
the crime his wife evidently also said
that he told her about the murders on
the morning like after they happened
even and he said he read about it in the
paper even though it wasn't printed in
the paper until the following morning so
they thought that was a little weird so
he actually got arrested and they put
him in jail
however while he was still in jail on
October 23rd 1981 there was another one
so it obviously couldn't been him so
they had him out the one that happened
in October of 1981 was a 24 year old
Susannah Camby and her boyfriend who was
26 his name was Stephano Baldy and they
were same thing they were in a car like
parked at a scenic outlook and the same
thing the killer came up you know shot
them basically just shot the man he was
half naked like I said they were
probably having sex in the car the
woman's body she was generally she was
found naked she'd been shot and stabbed
and mutilated now her vagina was also
removed but this time it was like a lot
floppier and a much larger section of
the area was taken
they said that part of her abdominal
cavity was like open so they're thinking
that probably the killer was rushed like
someone was coming or something like
that because it was a lot less precise
than the usual mutilations he had just
taken like a much larger chunk out of
her I know the flag [ __ ] horrible so
yeah so it said they both been shot
through the front window and they were
probably still alive like it's probably
the gun shots didn't kill them so at
this point you know that this is when
the media dubbed the killer because at
this point they thought it was the same
person doing all these they dubbed him
the monster of Florence also known as
the surgeon of death sometime or ill
Mastro sometimes they call him that too
but like I said it wasn't this enzo guy
because he was in prison when this other
crime took place so they I bet basically
just let him out because they said well
obviously it wasn't him so the next one
that took place was June 19th 1982 and
this was
hello Minardi who was 22 and his
girlfriend Antonella milly milly oriini
who was 20 and they same thing they were
having sex in a car someone came out of
the bushes and started shooting at them
um Antonella was killed outright Paola
actually lived but he died afterwards
like when they took him to hospital he
never regained consciousness so he
couldn't tell them who it was the
interesting thing about it though was
that the assistant DA at the time he
they will actually was one they they
kept it on the down-low
that Paola had died or that you know or
that he had never regained consciousness
they said we're gonna release it to the
media that he was still alive after the
crime which was true but he said we're
gonna say that he told the cops what the
killer looked like and we're gonna see
if we can like shake him out right smoke
him out that way yeah yes so it was
actually kind of a smart thing to do so
they actually did do that now it did
seem to make a difference because
weirdly after they published that in the
press then the person who I think it was
the person that had driven yeah it was
one of the emergency workers that had
responded to the police call for the
double murder they started getting all
these really weird phone calls from
somebody asking what pelo mera Nardi had
said you know I mean so presumably this
was the killer
like calling so that was like a good
lead but sadly it never came to anything
so even though they did they made a
gamble it did work out in the sense that
this person was calling for I don't know
why he was calling at one of the
emergency workers that responded to they
that's just seen and and the creepy
thing too I don't think that was the
killer I think it was newspapers it
might not yeah maybe but the weird thing
too was that this particular emergency
worker they even got a call later on
when they were on vacation
yeah somewhere else and they couldn't
figure out how this person knew where
that was there it might have devastated
trying to get the scoop right so at this
stage they compare all the shells all
that from all the crime scenes and they
figure out that the same gun has killed
all of these people and all the bullets
were from the same box okay so like I
said some people have been in jail some
people have been arrested like I said
the the guy that was suspected in the
first double murder
Stefan O'Malley who was the husband of
the first female victim he's still in
prison so obviously he couldn't have
done all of them and like I said the
anti Spalletti guy he was in prison like
they arrest him for one murder and then
there was another one while he was still
in jail that first guy who confessed to
killing his wife they know that his wife
was killed by that same firearm they all
of them were oh here's the thing though
I guarantee you they were all killed by
a 22 it doesn't necessarily mean that it
was the exact same 22 ballistic science
the ballistic science in terms of
forensics is not as good as people think
it is yet I mean yeah they've probably
just narrowed it down to it yeah they
were all killed by 22s it was all the
same brand of ammunition the rifling
pattern was the same which means that it
was the same brand of firearm but that
would sound like that would be you know
a dead you know like it like it like it
like that that would that that would
narrow it down but no 22s are very
common you know I mean yeah and a model
of 22 pistol can go into mass production
and in a place like Italy where they
don't have a whole lot of guns they
might they might all be Berettas you
know and there's a lot of those all
concentrated into one area we said they
said it was a Beretta yeah oh yeah
there's lots of those there and they
probably only had one or two different
brands ammunition available in the
country at that time because you know
they're tightly controlled there so I
guarantee you that was more than one
shooter I think that first guy did kill
his wife
the rest of him was a different shooter
well like I said that's why
investigators suspect that Stephano
Melly the
this guy who killed the wife and even
some of the other people were that were
suspects were kind of all working in
tandem like they were some kind of like
gang or like some kind of cult attempted
thing because they do think they're all
interrelated some of them did know each
other so they think that there might be
some of that kind of [ __ ] going on it
would it would be unlikely but maybe but
but not impossible could it have been
that just that they all were
interrelated because they all lived in
the same area you know what I mean in a
minute this might I don't know what the
population density is in this area we're
talking about him know Italy that well
well Florence is very large yeah but was
this happening all in one neighborhood
no no it was pretty it was pretty much
usually in like the surrounding areas
like around Florence where's the
evidence that there was a cult though or
a group of them just because they kind
of tangentially knew one another
yeah and like I said a lot of them knew
each other like the suspects knew each
other like I said you know they're
operating under the assumption this is
like you know the same gun or you know
some the gun that had been used in the
first one they're pretty sure that it
was using the other one and they know
that one of the guys that was charged
later that's his gun that could be one
guy just working his way through a scene
of friends though yeah that is possible
I think that's more likely than a group
of people you know I mean doing it and
it sounds like that same MO over and
over again Lovers Lane taking trophies
yeah pieces of women with that that
sounds like the work of one man not a
man because how do you get a bunch of
how do you get a group of people to go
well I don't think that they were all
doing I just think that they they're
thinking it wasn't like oh there's four
guys at each crime scene they're just
saying oh I did that one and I did that
one and I did that one type of thing I
think that first murder was not really
closely related to all the rest of them
I think all the subsequent ones after
that were I think that first ones that
that guy killed his wife out of jealousy
and the end the the boyfriend he just
happened to be using that same brand of
pistol which was which would have been
common in that area and that same brand
of ammunition and the police confused it
so they said well these this group of
murders here also you
that same brand and that same brand of
ammo on that same Beretta pistol so they
must be interrelated I don't think they
really were I'm just saying
statistically you know what I mean I
can't prove it I'm just saying it's more
likely that it's two separate two
separate killers they just kind of
happen to be overlapped you know I mean
it happened within same kind of group of
friends well that first does that first
double homicide there how was that
linked in with the rest of them what
links them same ballistics same gun same
type of ammo that's not enough and same
you know same MO like you know same area
they were parked in a car coincidence I
think it's coincidence if you asked me I
just well I'm gonna say okay so the next
murder the next double murder took place
in September of 1983 now this one is
kind of interesting because this is not
a man and a woman in a car it was two
men now most of the things about this
crime say it's like oh they were
homosexual lovers they had homosexual
porn in the car I don't know if that's
true or if that's just some [ __ ] that
you know somebody made up somewhere it
was just two guys they were West Germans
they were like on vacation in Italy and
they were camping and they were sitting
in a car and somebody came up and they
were like in a camper and somebody came
up and shot them now they were obviously
not mutilated police are speculating
that this was the same killer and that
he thought that it was a man and woman
in the car because one of the
individuals had kind of he had long
blonde hair it was very thin and so he
could have been mistaken for a woman
from the back or from far away that
sounds likely and so because they
weren't mutilated they figured the
killer just came up on and shot and I
discovered it was two guys yes their
names were Horst Meyer and ube Roush
sends those were they two victims that
time around so and again same it was a
22 beretta same the Winchester
ammunition same type of thing so okay at
this point obviously they know this is a
serial killer not only is there the same
modus operandi not only is there the
same
you know the same weapon same ballistics
all that other kind of stuff but also
they said the interesting thing too was
that all of the victims had been at
discos before on the night before they
were murdered they all almost all were
killed on Saturday night almost all of
them were killed during the new moon and
[ __ ] like that and sometime oast of the
female victims had their purses and
stuff like rummaged through like the
person was trying to find some kind of
trophies to take or something like that
at this stage they're sure they're
starting to think you know their
approach the police are approached by
like a religious historian who says hey
maybe it's a satanic cult or some [ __ ]
like that so then a year goes by and
then there's another one July 29th 1984
this was just north of Florence and this
was pretty much textbook just like the
other ones were the man's body was in
the backseat of the car he just had like
an undershirt and underwear on and then
outside of the car like behind the
bushes was the naked body of the female
victim and she had been stabbed a
hundred times had her vagina removed
also had her left breast wormy yet
that's that same killer right so you
know again same gun same everything same
knife even the they're saying it's like
it's the same knife same size so far the
only problem I have with this is that I
don't think that first double homicide
is directly related to the other ones
there is a serial killer here yeah it's
just that that first double homicide was
that was the husband yes use the same
ammo on the same pistol that's all and
in a place like Italy they're not gonna
have a big choice the big variation in
terms of guns and ammo like a good
example in Brazil in Brazil everything's
either a Rossi or a Taurus that's the
only thing they can get their hands on
yeah and when you talk about 22 is the
most common one that has a little nine
shop Taurus revolver everybody has that
[ __ ] gun in Brazil
pretty much and you know then then the
only the only ammunition they have a CBC
so if you shoot somebody with that nine
shot tourists using that CBC ammo you're
gonna have that same footprint as
everybody else out there yeah I mean in
that in that gun and that ammo selects
it has a vast swath of the market Italy
is going to be this
same kind of deal they're not like the
United States where you can just get
your hands on anything you know that's
what you're seeing so the next couple
that were murdered this is the last
known monster of Florence crime this
took place on September 8 1985 again
this was a vacationing couple they were
French they were in a tent just outside
of Florence they were camping out
apparently the killer came up cut a hole
in the tent and started shooting the
woman was shot four times in the head
and the throat and the man was also shot
four times in the face and in the arm
evidently they said the shots had been
fired very close range less than 12
inches
they said the couple were probably
having sex at the time they think the
woman was on top of the man when you
know the person just cut up in the tent
and started shooting in there so
evidently the the guy like the woman was
killed outright because she got shot in
the head the man was shot but apparently
tried to run away
because they found him a little way away
and then the killer stabbed him to death
and then the killer goes back into the
tent and cuts out the woman's vagina and
also takes her left breast again now the
creepy thing about this is that later on
the killer sent like a very Zodiac type
letter it was like a letter with pasted
you know letters from magazines and [ __ ]
like that and it included her nipple
though yeah although I mean very
recently it has been speculated that the
Zodiac and this person were the same
person no I'm not lying it no like some
guy named Bevilaqua I think his name is
like somebody have just put forth that
theory is just trying to sell books
ourselves yes all right so I mean it
sounds like an Italian song saying it
Son of Sam case so that was the last of
the so-called monster of Florence crimes
now over the following years in the
1990s another suspect begins to come to
the fore and his name
is Pietro Gianni now he was sex 68 years
old at the time kind of he was a farmer
uh not super bright kind of not really
all that literate um he had actually
he'd been arrested for a murder before
in 1951 he had murdered salesmen who had
come to his door he had stabbed him and
like stomped him to death so you know he
had been in prison for 13 years and then
actually after he got out he supposedly
had a normal life got married had some
daughters but then he was arrested again
in 1987 for spousal abuse and for
molesting his daughters so there also so
when they you know arrest this guy and
they're questioning this guy apparently
and this again this is where the occult
you know thing is coming from two is
that they figure out that pot Ianno is
in this little loose group of sort of
like a cult interested people with three
other guys whose names are Mario Vani
Giovanni Fauji and Giancarlo Lodi who
were also like peeping tom type dudes
they would like go out at night look at
people's windows and all this other kind
of [ __ ]
they also allegedly according to
witnesses had black masses where they
used like you know female body parts and
stuff like that which made police very
interested because you know obviously
all these women's vaginas were being
taken so there I mean there was some
kind of like controversy about that
because some of the cops were like no
he's too much of a dummy to plan these
he be you know he was buying and stuff
like that um so actually they they put
him on trial in 1994 it was like a huge
thing was in all the newspapers it's
like they the prosecutors wanted this to
be tell at televise so this for
anybody's are just the one that he did
um for yeah for this group of murders
for pretty much most of them other than
the first two I think okay so so they
put him on trial in 1994 but again you
know they didn't have a hell of a lot of
you know really solid
circumstantial evidence he did get
convicted eventually and sentenced to
life in prison that group of murders
yeah very famously very famously as they
were dragging him out of court he said
he was as innocent as Christ on the
cross probably probably true although he
did a bunch he did do this some other
shade on the murder in 1951 and he did
beat his wife and molest his daughters
so you know I feel too bad yeah well you
know Italy's kind of notorious for
framing people for murders I mean well
now a terrible criminal justice system
he actually um his conviction was
overturned not that long afterward in
1996 yeah I am buying that the dude who
did all those shootings all right
Talan he was a young guy and he was an
in cell you know I mean he wasn't
married he didn't have daughters he
wasn't he was a he was a Berkowitz type
guy young nerd angry and you know
typical himself he was like that that's
who that was who would be driven to that
kind of rage why focus in on people
having sex you know yeah but um okay so
anyway like I said he had these three
associates so they kind of start looking
into the associates 1997 two of the
associates Mario Vani and Giancarlo
Lochte they went on trial also for five
of the double murders they were also
convicted sentenced to life the first
guy was sentenced to life the second guy
was sent to 26 years Pat Gianni was
actually gonna be retried after they
kind of found some new evidence and
after some of the other you know one of
the other guys like said that he thought
jenny was involved but he actually died
before he could be brought back to trial
okay so Mario Boni and Giancarlo Lotte
were still in jail Pacino died before he
could be retried in 2001 the
investigation was reopened to see if
they could find any more people they
actually said at this point that they
had 10 to 12 more suspects that they
were looking at and like I said they
thought it was some kind of ritualistic
you know web of kind of wealthy yeah
sort of people that were kind of all
acting together yeah they're lying
so they actually rated some people's
houses like some kind of higher up
people and found evidently found some
incriminating photos and things like
that in their houses so you know we'll
see how that goes
so I think the last thing like I said
the last thing that happened with this
was yeah somebody published something in
2018 as I said before somebody saying
that they think that this is the same
person as the zodiac Giuseppe Bevilaqua
and they actually have they've actually
figured out you know that I think it's
like the eight last 18 characters of the
of the cipher that were never deciphered
the first zodiac cipher they claimed
that that says his actual name that
spells out his actual name he must have
heard about the zodiac but yeah like I
said so at this stage like I said two of
the guys that were like suspected are in
jail one of the guys is dead they claim
they have a bunch of more suspects they
think that it's at least four people
that it's not just one person so and
that's pretty much where the monster of
Laurens case stands like I said Hannibal
is kind of based on this case like not
just the kind of the subplot is based on
this there was actually a really good
book about it I can't remember who wrote
it now but it's like a nonfiction book
that was kind of about this case also so
if you want to check that out you should
all put the link in the description
because I can't remember the author
right now but it's actually it's it's
one of Italy's most famous cases it's
it's weird that's not better known here
because it's like I said it's very
similar to the zodiac very similar to
phantom killer type stuff and there's
you know the whole genital mutilation
thing yeah so that was the monster of
Florence case we're gonna take a break
right now because we've got on and on
and on yeah and then after we come back
we will talk about another European true
crime case the serial killer known as
the vampire or the butcher of Hanover
pervy ass europeans man there's a pervy
so yeah so we're America okay like
there's a difference there's some [ __ ]
up people here - I've talked about all
kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] down here okay
alright so we're gonna take a break we
will be back in just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
paper at the end of the day buddy
Jenny's got some new shirt designs up
four of them really good ones to Atlanta
Ripper who put Bella in the which out
the HH Holmes murder castle and of
course demon child cuz man said he could
these are updated designs I think they
look really cool Jenny did a great job
autumn where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out really good
they're very high-quality shirts Jenny
and I we're sure our own shirts at
certain times when we're trying to put
spotlight on ourselves and you can put a
spotlight on yourselves if you go ahead
and pick up on these shirts today you
guys are gonna love them links in the
description
WWL comm at 13 o'clock yeah so go check
out our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one of the old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out they're also available in women's
cut and they look really cute JD's got
some so thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back on this European
true-crime spectacular yeah and I'm
running with Google calm yeah love it
when I you know when I start running car
with Kukulcan you know I guess I'm the
comedic relief yes sometimes yeah I
suppose hope to serve as the audience
yeah I mean I only know what the
audience knows so I'll answer quick I'll
ask questions you know talking about
unless they know more about the case
that they might know more than me that's
not the audience that's individuals
within the audience okay all right so
this was actually master Florence was
recommended this was also recommended
and this was a another serial killer
that I had never heard of I'm really
need to get up on my serial killers I
mean I'm a true crime writer for [ __ ]
sake and there's so many that I haven't
heard of which I guess it's kind of
horrifying because there's so many out
there now this was actually a long time
ago this guy alternately known as the
vampire pan over the butcher of Hanover
or the Wolfman okay this guy uh they
know who he is
his name is Friedrich Fritz Harmon
sounds familiar
yeah he murdered between the years of
1918 and 1920 for that they know of
murdered between 24 and 27 boys and
young men although he confessed that
probably it was more like 50 ish and
they just never found the people which
probably was the case so he was a
homosexual killer yes
all right now he was actually here's the
thing like he grew up in a very poor
family and like you know this was the
late 19th century in Germany you know
there was a lot of you know bad [ __ ]
going on so evidently he showed sadistic
tendencies from quite a young age he
used to really dig like tying up his
sisters and doing all that kind of stuff
and like scaring them he really got off
on [ __ ] with people and inflicting
pain inflicting fear he also showed
homosexual tendencies very
early he always preferred like hanging
out with girls doing kind of girl he's
playing with dolls you know doing baking
and things like that which were
considered feminine at the time also
when he got a little bit older he was
kind of like a tall well-built fella but
he he had a felt like a very womanly
voice and you know the way he walks was
very you know very stereotypically gay I
suppose he has ambiguous so there was
that thing but the interesting thing
like he goes to school he doesn't do
very well in school you know obviously
he's got some mental problems they
called it at the time they they called
it dementia praecox which i think is
kind of like the old timey term first
schizophrenia um but he was recognized
as like having some mental problems
quite early on so he actually did go to
a military academy and he really liked
it there
and he did quite well as far as I know
but they actually let him go after he
started having seizures I don't know if
it was epileptic seizures or if they
just sit they just said like he kept get
going unconscious and he kept like
having all these so he had like a lot of
mental problems and a lot of health
problems that could be anything right
right so right around now he was born in
1879 I don't know if I said in those
days that could have even been diabetes
yeah was really going to do you know
diabetes diabetics sometimes pass out
yeah so around the end of the 19th
century we're on 1898 he was actually
arrested for child molestation hmm now
when he stood trial for this they said
that he was psychologically unfit to San
Charles they sent him to a mental
institution hmm now he was there for
about six months and then he escaped and
then he went to Switzerland so he stayed
in Switzerland for a while he came back
to Germany when he was about 20 years
old and he actually married a woman
named Edna lowered and he got her
pregnant
but then he abandoned her hmm then he
joined the army like I said when they
interviewed him later on he said
actually being in the military was like
the happiest time of his life
most of his superior officers said that
he was a very good soldier he was very
obedient he was a he was an excellent
marksman and he did like a very he was
like really into it and he did a really
good job however apparently during a
military exercise he kept like
collapsing again it's this sort of on
unspecified like mental illness or
unspecified physical illness that he has
so he keeps collapsing and they are like
well you can't stay here because you
can't you can't do your duties you have
some kind of mental deficiency so he was
discharged and he went back to live with
his family now they this is so funny
like his parents evidently him and his
dad did not get along so his dad tries
to put him in a another mental
institution the mental institution
wouldn't take him because the doctor
said he was quote-unquote morally
inferior what does that mean which I was
like that could mean a lot of things gay
it could mean that that could very well
be like a euphemistic because this was
like yeah like 1900 or something maybe
they act maybe because I've read about
Fritz Hartmann um
they said he was very obviously gay yeah
um and he didn't apparently make much of
a secret of it right so it's primal
that's probably what they mean so they
said okay without thing man for some
reason I'm thinking this is epilepsy
they're not absolutely diabetes I'm
thinking diabetes I don't think I knew
about diabetes that back then did they I
don't know I don't know when it was
discovered now I have to like Wikipedia
yeah Mitch that's diabetes is probably
nothing more than that because if he did
well in a structured environment he
liked the military yeah so I don't think
there would be any kind of mental stress
on him you know a lot of guys love the
military you know especially guys had
end up having problems like this yeah so
I think the only thing that would
prevent him from thriving was some kind
of the
physical ailment and passin out you know
I don't really think there being a
flashing lights to bring on epilepsy you
know I bet you it was nothing more than
just diabetes yeah blood sugar gets low
II thought yeah and falling out you know
so after I've done that yeah a few times
myself super low blood pressure
I liked that person oh yeah
so okay so he gets out of the military
he doesn't go to an asylum because he's
morally inferior um he tried to open up
a business for a little while didn't
really work out so he said well I'm just
gonna go into a life of crime now the
first crimes that he got kind of into
when he was a con man pretty much he
would I know this is very weird but I
guess in this period of Germany and I
was you know people didn't you know it
was very poor they didn't have a lot of
things and so there was like a big black
market in like stolen clothing and all
these kind of things that people
couldn't get normally so he actually
would do that kind of stuff he started
trading and like clothing and meat and
things like that like on the black
market now he got arrested a whole bunch
of times like in this ensuing period and
he got so well known to the police and
Hanover where he lived that he
eventually said because the police force
was kind of so understaffed and you know
they didn't really have so they said
they were like encouraging the public to
be like informant so he said well I'll
be a police informant which is kind of
funny when you turn on the do turn up
this serial killer later on but he's
like yeah he started being a police
informant in 1918 which also was that
would also serve to kind of allay
suspicion from his like I'm a police
informant I would never be a serial
killer of course not why would you even
and it worked for a while it worked for
about six years actually six seven years
but he did have some kind of
misdemeanors and [ __ ] like that in there
but then came September 25th 1918 and
evidently his first victim that they
know of was a 17 year old named Friedel
Rosa and he what he would do what what
Hartmann would do he liked to pick
guys are teenage boys like from the
Hanover train station and he would
either tell them that he was a cop
or tell them because he was a police
informant or he would tell them that he
had a job for them and you know since it
was kind of a lot of Runaways and stuff
like that so he was kind of getting like
a pretty steady supply of like these
kind of teenage runaways and stuff like
that hey come back to my house I'll give
you a meal I'll give you some work you
know or I'm a cop I'm arresting you for
whatever and then he would take them
back and kill them
so he takes this first boy and evident
find out about this until much later on
but he takes the first boy back to his
house and because the his friends had
seen this boy going with Fritz Hartmann
the friends reported it to the police so
the police actually rated for its
Herman's apartment after this first
victim they didn't search it though now
they didn't find the original kid but
they did find Fritz Hartmann in bed with
another kid Yeah right like a 13 year
old boy or something with him and with
him yeah so he actually got arrested for
sexual assault right now later on after
all of his crimes came to light and
stuff he's like oh I'm so glad the cops
didn't search the apartment at the time
because the original kid's head was
wrapped up in newspaper and stashed
behind the stove hmm so you know and the
other kid in bed with him didn't know
where's the rest of the body I don't
well no I'll go get okay so he
eventually gets out you know he like I
said he got arrested on sexual assault
charge um but like I said they didn't
search his house so they didn't think he
had anything to do with the original
kid's murder who was named Friedel wrote
that like I said now at this point at
the train station the same place where
he picked up all those victims he meets
this guy named Hans groans now Hans
groans evidently he was kind of a con
man too like a low-level con man now he
approached Fritz Hartmann because like I
said he saw that for terment was a gay
man now Hans was heterosexual he had a
girlfriend everything like that
he was kind of trying to make some money
and he said go well here's a gay man I'm
gonna go up there and offer my sexual
services so he comes up to him and the
two of them strike up a friendship now
the creepy thing is like the two of
these guys they eventually moved in
together and like Hans knew about all of
this [ __ ] like I don't know if I don't
think he killed any of the victims or
anything like that but they did live
together and he didn't know about it I
mean he knew that he was killing the
guys yes he just let it roll yes they
ride he did no Dan yeah he's a crook yes
so they move in together
yeah and at this stage like Fritz
Hartmann is just he's just kind of going
and [ __ ] so what he would do like I
said his his usual mo he goes to the
train station tries to pick up Runaways
he says he's a cop usually and he says
I'm arresting you for whatever then he
would take the boys back to his place
sometimes he would keep them for a few
days like raping them and stuff like
that how he would kill them was he would
simultaneously strangle them and also
pull out their Adam's apple like with
his teeth like he would bite her throat
and like pull like was strangling yeah
which is which is why he got the epithet
the vampire head over or the Wolfman and
how these really how old were these kids
um the youngest one was 10
they were anywhere from like 10 to early
20s usually they were usually some
physical physical strike - yeah he
wasn't like I said he the way he walks
away he talked was effeminate but
everything I've read around said he was
you know a rather well built like a
broad-shouldered apartment raped him
over a couple of days sometimes okay
wonder how he kept control over him they
must been tied up or we just maybe keep
it mental control yeah the creepy thing
- is that what he would do is he would
generally he would cut them up yeah now
he would there's actually no solid
evidence of this but they're assuming
that this is what because he dealt in
black-market meat oh so and most of this
is most of the meat that he sold was in
mitts form yeah he's grinding him up
yeah
so they're pretty sure that a lot of the
meat that I sold was human me yeah this
has happened to several time in the
history of Syria they had one dude that
he won some kind of chili contest with
victim meat in the chili fact that other
people are eating the evidence eat yeah
eat him up now serious like he had
killed a lot of people like I said then
there's 24 to 27 that they know of you
know and they know that there was a lot
more than that because in this period
like between the wars in Germany you
know there's a lot of poverty there was
a lot of runaways there was a lot of
crime there like [ __ ] it just in the
first year you started killing they were
like 600 like young boys that have run
away from homes that they were missing
and they didn't know where they were so
you know he was kind of operating in
this in this kind of area where who
knows - how many [ __ ] people he he
wasn't even sure honestly yeah I mean
just to remind any new listeners any new
viewers that era that era 1800s Early
1900s you could get away with some
serious [ __ ] there wasn't there wasn't
any paperwork
yeah not to speak of that's what I mean
like I said work they have such thing is
the good old days now it wasn't the good
old days look at HH Holmes [ __ ]
he built a damn murder palace yeah and
the thing is is like even like all the
serial killers here's the thing there's
probably like a [ __ ] ton of serial
killers back then one but they don't
even know about because they never
caught them um - even the ones that they
did catch I bet they killed a lot more
people than they know of yeah because
all you had to do like I said and I
think I've said this before all you had
to do is move to another [ __ ] state
and change your name and that was oh
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] here's the thing I mean he
he's biting these kids throats out how
does he how does he keep the sounded
down what kind of apartment is this the
creepy thing too is that when he when he
killed the second kid yeah right his
second victim yeah evidently Hans groans
his Lowell his roommate yeah came home
and saw the dead body on the bed like
after it happened all Hans said was oh
should I come back later like something
like that I'm like oh my god so yeah so
like I said he killed that guy was
looking for
yeah he killed like shit-tons people
this way one he would normally do they
didn't find out about him cuz like I
said he'd been in prison he'd been like
for a little [ __ ] mostly I mean so it
was sexual assault that's not little
[ __ ] but I mean just like for conman
type [ __ ] so the police knew of him and
obviously he was an informant and he was
supposedly helping them but they didn't
they didn't relate him to any of these
boys going missing right but then in
1924 these two little kids are like
playing along the line of river and they
found I think they've had a skull right
or like a jar part of a skull yeah and
when they start like dredging the river
and looking around the river they found
like 500 bones that they think belonged
to at least 22 to 24 people and later on
when they interviewed for its Herman he
said yeah that's what I would do it's
like I would grind the flesh up for me
and he's like then I would usually try
to smash up the bones kind and then I
just threw them in the river so this
whole [ __ ] River they dredged it
there's just like full of bones that
he's been throwing in there oh because
she doing this in his apartment yeah
okay
all right he's [ __ ] crazy man yeah
now the creepy thing so at this stage
the last person he killed was another 17
year old his name was Eric DeVries guys
sounded a lot like Dahmer yeah he's very
dumb very much like Dahmer yeah he's
like the proto Dahmer yeah I want to say
like the German Berto so at this stage
when he killed the last victim police
are already you know suspecting
obviously there's a serial killer and
they're kind of doing this big manhunt
and he he actually did kind of come onto
their radar so the police started to
watch him so in 1924 in June of 1924
they caught him trying to lure a 15 year
old boy named Karl Fromm from the train
station where he normally picked up all
his victims now apparently Fromm told
them he's like yeah I was in his
apartment before like for several days
and he raped me a bunch of times but see
the thing is homosexuality was
obviously very illegal back then you
could go to jail for it so I think he
kind of used that to his advantage
because he knew that even if he raped
the boys and let them go they're not
gonna tell anybody because you know they
might go to prison or they might you
know get aspersions cast upon them so I
think he used that to his advantage like
he was canny enough to do that so yeah
so this kid said yeah I was there before
and he brings me a bunch of times and
then Fred's finally was like yeah I was
gonna kill him but you know I decided
not to or whatever so finally the police
go and they search Fritz's apartment
finally and there's just blood
everywhere now at first Fritz is saying
oh well you know I'm in the meat
business so I'm just you know butchering
carcasses not humans I swear like in my
[ __ ] apartment right but yeah he
didn't really they didn't really fall
for that so it didn't actually take all
that long before Fritz was like yeah you
got me it's me so he did actually
confess right away
and they said that he was actually
pretty forthcoming once they once they
had him in custody and they were like
look we know it's you and all this other
stuff so he actually did kind of you
know give up all the details they said
weirdly the only time that he would get
quiet was one when he was confronted
with the families of the victims because
he did like some of the parents of the
boys like what came and like talked to
him and then he'd get really really
quiet or when they talked about
beheading like that seemed to bother him
a lot because he did behead most of his
victims I mean a lot of the victims are
just found skulls and [ __ ] like that so
like I said he said that he couldn't
really remember how many people he
killed he's like it might be 50 might be
a hundred I'm not sure that's 24 to 27
that they know of that are like
positively identified that were you know
attributed to him so he was actually put
on trial in 1924 one of the weird quotes
that he used to say was that he really
wanted to be decapitated like he thought
that would be I don't know if like he
thought it would be some kind of sexual
rush that's kind of the impression that
I guess
like quick your that or he thought there
to be kind of like a just rewards maybe
yeah but it's I don't know it's like
super you might have had some kind of
weird fetish about it yeah then the
weird thing to was that at his trial he
also tried to pin a bunch of the [ __ ] on
Hans his roommate the creepy thing is
that Hans actually did get convicted of
one of the murders or accessory to the
murder and he got executed
yeah but then later on cuz I think he
was executed first and then first harm
was executed later and he was like oh by
the way Hans didn't do anything you
executed it and it's that guy like how
do you like that kind of thing so yeah
it was that it was that separate but
Hans knew about it yeah he did he didn't
know he knew all those kids were gonna
being killed so really he wasn't an
innocent if he asked me yes so there was
like this whole kind of [ __ ] sick
game between his like yeah I'm just
trying to like do it on Hans and [ __ ]
like that
so the trial lasted about two weeks he
got convicted of all but three of the
murders they were trying to pin on him
and actually in April of 1925 they
actually did they cut his head off with
a guillotine yeah and they actually
here's the sad thing like because like I
said he dumped most of their remains in
the river lane and they found like all
these bodies was like at least 22 people
so they've they're all buried like in a
mass grave there's like a big huge like
a triptych gravestone with all their
names on it you know still there
obviously but I you know I don't know I
just I thought that was really weird
really creepy really first I've heard of
this guy yeah there any sounds a lot
like Dahmer he does yeah did he didn't
he he didn't eat any of them himselves
well he did bite it into their throat he
bite he called it his love bite oh
really yeah pulling their Adam's apple
that was it yeah that must take quite a
force to do that though that's what I
was thinking I'm like god damn maybe he
lied he must have some strong jaw power
maybe he lied though it could be because
like I said I don't you know i don't
think they didn't find any bodies in
fact they were like pretty much all
bones and they'd been cut apart and he
might have sold the meat yeah i mean
also when they searched his apartment
they found
like a bunch of clothes that belonged to
a lot of the missing people yeah and he
was trying to write it off like oh I'm
you know cuz not only did he deal in
black-market meat he also dealt in
black-market clothes he's like yeah I
got clothes you know I don't know where
I got those from blah blah blah but you
know he confess in the end so they
[ __ ] knew how I did it what he did so
yeah they actually kept his head for a
long time at the medical school they
kept it in a jar but then in 2014 they
finally cremated it so that [ __ ] man
it's like listen to this [ __ ] this is
this is a quote that I found from this
[ __ ] and this is him describing
what he would do with the victims he's
like I'd make two cuts in the abdomen
and put the intestines in a bucket then
soak up the blood and crush the bones
until the shoulders broke now I could
get the heart lungs and kidneys and chop
them up and put them in my bucket I take
the flesh off the bones and put it in my
wax cloth bag it would take me five or
six trips to take everything and throw
it down the toilet or into the river I
always hated doing this but I couldn't
help it my passion was so much stronger
than the horror of the cutting and
chopping he had he had that thing like
that some serial killers have where
because he had some other quotes to
where he's just like sometimes he would
have these kids at his house and just
like I knew that if they were there a
long time like something bad was gonna
happen
like I couldn't help myself and although
he had that kind of [ __ ] yeah so yeah
and like I said that [ __ ] [ __ ] about
like tearing out their throats and like
calling them Love Bites and stuff like
that that's [ __ ] yeah and he
sodomized some of them also like I said
he was he was also a rapist in addition
to being a murderer and then they would
take all this junk then he would take
all their stuff like their clothes and
their possessions and stuff and sell
them on the black market and allegedly
sell their meat on the black market as
well
well serial killer is primarily a serial
rapist they just kill them well yeah
you've said yeah before me they're their
rapists first yeah that's why they're
doing it interestingly and I did not
know that notice until I started
researching this case but the very
famous movie
yeah it's partially based on this guy
huh there have actually been a couple of
movies based on this guy one of them is
called the tenderness of wolves from
1973 and one of them called is called
the death maker that came out in 1985
that is also based on him yeah a serial
killer is a serial rapist yeah but you
have guys like you know Berkowitz son
Sam you know like Berkowitz you guys to
just shoot people in lovers lanes like
the first one the reason why they're
really not raping people is because they
can't get it up that's all it is that
might be the case in the monster of
Florence thing if it's not a cult thing
I have heard some people say wanna rape
people but it was probably right
particularly because the second set of
the second woman that was killed had
like the grapevine inserted into her
they have performance anxiety
yeah and they may be virgins yeah so
that's something else you have to put
you know take an account yeah they don't
know how to have sex I'm scared that
they're scared they won't their
performance will be bad so they just
shoot a [ __ ] that's in there because
that much that's obviously so much
better yeah so much better well you know
there's sad sacks I don't get it
but yeah so again like I was saying
before about about Hans groans Fritz
Harmons roommate it should be noted that
one of the victims had a handkerchief
that had Hans is his name on it like
stuffed into his throat hmm so I'm
thinking like I said Hans got executed
and then like afterward Fritz was like
nah he didn't do it you killed an
innocent guy haha but like nah dude
wasn't it yeah I don't think like I said
I don't know if he killed any of the
dudes but he for sure knew about I mean
we knew the guy yeah he knew he was
bringing like dudes he was bringing kids
home from the [ __ ] train station all
the time and like I said who knows how
many people it was so there's only like
a six-year-old poured a crime like that
then you're guilty of that crime you
just watch it happen unless you're like
[ __ ] tied up and do anything or the
unless the guy like they're insecure if
you don't if you don't you know go in
there and stop it you're guilty if you
ask me
like I said some [ __ ] like that out of
best of that mother beat that
[ __ ] ass like I said in lesson
two exonerating circumstance like you
can't get away children loose man yes
scared of that dude if I was living with
him if he was bigger than me I couldn't
handle mine just go get a gun or a knife
yeah and then go to the car like that
yeah yeah like I said the sad thing was
like they didn't even know what this
[ __ ] guy was doing until like some
kids found a [ __ ] skull in the river
and then they just started dredging up
was like what the [ __ ] are all these
people I said knife that was just
something off the top of my head really
knife suck in comparison to just a damn
stick the blunt force trauma Scout
stopping power everybody's always wanted
to go for these knives just get a
baseball yeah yeah it takes too long but
a nice big punk to the head just knocks
him out that's what I mean it's like I'm
just saying like I don't know you know
what I mean I'm not a murderer
but it's like but I've done a lot of
research in this area
just look up medieval weapons yeah it's
like even people that are shot or
stabbed or some like you have to like
hit him in pretty and a few very
strategic locations for them to die
because people have been stabbed
multiple times and still live people
have been shot multiple times it's still
lived if you take a big-ass baseball bat
like you said and crack someone in the
back of the skull they can't they can't
they're probably not gonna get up I mean
even in the medieval times you know
pound for pound when you were dealing
with somebody who was unarmored the mace
was the way to go and that was just
nothing but a baseball bat with a heavy
weight on the end of it sometimes spikes
just one blow anywhere to the body
usually just take you out hit you in the
elbow take an arm out hit you in the
back end just send you down hit you in
the head that was it you're through you
just crushed you and it would crush you
even if you had played armor on because
it just but just you know cram the armor
in on you yeah you know the movies are
always showing you how awesome the sword
was the sword wasn't really all that
good if it's more of a status symbol
what was good was things like the Mason
that battle-ax I was just thinking while
you were saying that that it's like
human heads are really so fragile
blunt-force trauma has stopping power
considering how important the brain is
I'm
yeah we have the skull and everything
and that's like cool I mean I'm glad
that it's there but it seems like it's
really not that all you got to do is
slip and fall on your [ __ ] bathroom
floor and that [ __ ] up you could get
brain damage and then that's some
evolution that's some [ __ ] evolution
you do all the reading and you go if you
do all the reading of what you know the
testimony from these killers what they
said happened during certain homicides
that they committed
you can tell who has experience and who
doesn't
guys that do things like grabbing
hammers okay and hitting somebody in the
head with a hammer not not really a good
weapon it gets stuck in the sculpt pops
a hole in the skull and that gets stuck
in a pulley you have to hit him again
you want something big like a baseball
bat or Claude Lee and mountain cave man
they grabbed a knife and you'll hear you
know the newspaper stabbed 37 times what
took 37 stab wounds to kill the person
knives aren't that good like I said they
don't have stopping I have to say this
is one thing it's like more seriously
we're not murderers and we're not we're
not advocating anybody become murderers
this is something that has this bothers
me in movies I know there's like [ __ ]
about guns it bothers you movies yeah
this bothers me about knives somebody
gets stabbed in the back like in someone
it's like not even a major organs and
they immediately just fall over dead
yeah it doesn't happen that well it does
not happen like that it just doesn't
once tabloid that's not gonna kill you
even if it did it would take a long time
takes a long time much have to bleed out
to bleed out you have to take out time I
mean you know like I said it's like some
of these people were stabbed like
[ __ ] a hundred times there were
stabbed a hundred times sure I've seen
videos of a girl being stabbed to death
this is over in Turkey she was working
behind the counter and had the security
camera on her and she was having a you
know she was leaving her husband her
husband came in there with a knife and
stabbed her to death it took a long time
he couldn't see all of it because she
fell down on the ground and tried to
hide from him underneath the counter she
was working lies you would and you could
hear her screaming saying no and he's
and he must have stabbed her 30 or 40
times and then he ran out and she was
still alive
she ended up dying later well like I
said I've written about some [ __ ] yeah
books where I mean where some women were
stabbed like dozens and dozens
times and it took them a really long
time huh yeah [ __ ] I was I've seen some
cases were like a woman was like shot in
the face and she's still gonna die right
away it took like a month or two and
then a single blow to the head with a
baseball bat just kill you or you or
you're out you're down for the count
yeah you wake up days later in the
hospital just that's just one blow
protip for the zombie apocalypse yeah
probably a baseball blunt-force trama
always kind of a long baseball bat so
you can hit him from know what I mean so
they don't to get too close you don't
want the bitee teeth there was a surge
in Jim and had the right idea Japan
Japan had a master swordsman you know oh
[ __ ] now I've been running with cool
Colin forgot his name
[ __ ] Kukulcan I'll tell you yeah yeah I
was thinking it was good I was gonna sit
musashi okay yeah massage my bad
now Musashi he took out a lot of guys
with bladed weapons but as he got went
up and skill he said I you know swords
too easy I'm just gonna use a practice
sword which is a piece of wood and he
started killing guys with that all right
unbeknownst to the average person though
a blow to the head with that that
practice sword that piece of wood had
better stopping power than a damn sword
it would kill you and then I think he
figured that out you don't have to cut
somebody just a heavy blow to the head
you know what it would have impressed me
more but it would scare everybody else
cuz you're being killed by do the
practice sword then he said you know
what [ __ ] that I'm not gonna use the
sword you challenged because he didn't
want he didn't want to take these
challenges everybody was challenging him
to duels he was sick of that [ __ ] go
anywhere he was sick so what he would do
is he was just so Katie challenged me
I'm just gonna kill you with a boat
paddle so he just started can't be with
boat oars but a paddle imagine the
dishonor and these are samurai yeah he
was killed by a boat or do you know
would be more rad if he told people with
the plastic spoon they didn't have those
but okay that would that would have
impressed me or like or like a fluffy
like something fluffy like a little
pillow kill somebody the pillow you put
over there
musashi said that the really what
mattered when it came is to swords and
and and you know any kind of melee
weapon was the length of the weapon so
he always made sure his sword was a few
inches longer than everybody else's is
that a Dickey from ISM now what I was
gonna do the reach it had to do with
reach all right he'd hold the sword in a
way where the opponent couldn't really
figure out how long his sword was done
about okay you're killing me you're
killing me between girls I'm talking to
the man I'm not you can hold the sword
and away facing you so the blade was
going out in the back he couldn't tell
how long it was so you couldn't judge
how close you could get to him make a
bow he hit you with a sword on top of
the head and cleave your head or a stick
yeah the better you reached and you know
the more of a [ __ ] that's your
fault is there a strategy involved with
like you guys don't have anything better
to do then walk around in ancient Japan
like walking the little dirt roads hey
there's a guy I'm gonna challenge that
guy to a fight to the death
cuz they didn't have anything else to do
we're talking about Musashi now so
Musashi was basically an outlaw well he
was a lot of things it was a fugitive
ex-con ex-mercenary didn't have jobs so
now you work for people's armies she's
playing it as a joke I just see them
okay all right I gotta go alright we're
gonna this this show is gonna far too
long yes I'm out of here on very look at
you stay until the end he leaves me to
do everything so bye okay Tom says we
have to shut the show down now hopefully
you guys enjoy this I know it was like
it says it's a horribly serious topic
and we're just like being but that's
that's how we do I'm sorry anyway if you
like the show remember to Like share
subscribe on all your social media share
with all your friends relatives
neighbors people you don't like whatever
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast
don't work press calm and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account where
you can make a one-time donation if
you'd like to do that we would
appreciate it very much
also check out our Azazel store
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we have lots
of t-shirts and a tote bag that you can
choose from and our last video review
our last movie review rather was the
Evil Dead and also our last matinee
which was like new movies that we saw in
the theater
episode 2 I just put up a couple of days
ago so go check that out if you haven't
already and that will do it for haha
that will do it for episode 114 we will
see you next time for the Halloween show
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]